alalalala mais qu'est ce qu'il peut bien
fait toujours en retard
bonjour ça va et ben moi ça va pas du
tout j'attends casimir il est toujours
en retard françois oui tu as vu casimir
non tu me cherche aussi à bompas que toi
aussi
mais oui c'est nous ne sommes pas les
seuls monsieur du synode et la main
depuis une demi-heure il attend casimir
le sait je crois qu'il n'est pas du tout
de bonne humeur
mais qu'est ce qui peut bien faire enfin
tu sais que nous allons finir par nous
fâcher de terrain gelé
il arrive qu'elles évaluent
tu as pensé à mon petit livre de cuisine
ah non j'ai oublié beaucoup de casimir
ça n'est pas sérieux tu sais bien que je
suis perdu sans mon petit livre de
cuisine
je ne te le prêtre est plus bon ne t'en
fais pas julie je vais retourner chez
moi je reste là je reviens tout de suite
pourquoi est il parti si vite je n'ai
même pas eu le temps de lui demander
s'il m'avait rapporté mon poste de radio
mais ne t'inquiète pas il a été chercher
mon petit livre de cuisine il revient
tout de suite
ton livre de cuisine oui j'ai des
invités chez toi ce soir mais non mais
je me trompe toujours dans les mesures
quelles mesures les mesures d'âge gâteau
tu sais bien que dans un gâteau il y a
par exemple du beurre de la farine des
oeufs du sucre de l'eau du sel
c'est bien possible et bien si tu te
trompes dans les mesures si tu mets par
exemple trop de farine ton gâteau
devient comme de la pierre
si tu mets trop 2 il devient comme une
ombre
alors tu comprends comme c'est important
les mesures et comme je n'ai pas de
mémoire et bien il faut toujours mon
petit livre dit moi je les je ne savais
pas aussi gourmande mais ça n'est pas
pour moi que je fais les gâteaux pour
les enfants mais non plus bien pour pour
monsieur du snob ou le facteur peut-être
pas davantage pour casimir
pour livres de cuisine veux tu sais il
fallait pas cause comme ça ça n'était
pas une minuterie quand tu sais ce qui
pour nous est promis donc tu a réussit à
tarte aux pommes ah oui elle était
parfaite tu sais piquante et crémeuse
tout jaune un délicieuse les pommes
étaient bien cuites les pommes
non je n'avais pas pas non alors j'ai
mis en place des poires et des tomates
avec une couche de moutarde de la
confiture de fraises et des anchois
c'était délicieux tétouan kazimierz
c'est horrible quasi mais tu es parti
chez toi à l'autre bout de l'île et tu
es revenu en si peu de temps
what et alors je te félicite tués de
plus en plus sportifs à merci je suis
content que tu t'en aperçois re est due
à penser à leur apporter mon petit poste
de radio
ton petit poste de radio et mais non
pourquoi
parce que tu m'avais promis de leur
apporter aujourd'hui ans j'ai oublié ne
bouge pas en france moi jamais pour une
minute
j'en reviens tu es fini quasiment le
foot courir comme ça tu as raison je
n'ai jamais vu casimir courir aussi vite
et aussi longtemps que je n'ai même pas
eu le temps de parler de monsieur du
shom regard de luge aldo tournée n'a
certainement pas vu arriver ni repartir
tu devrais aller lui dire de venir
attendre avec nous parce que s'il
restait la barre sur le long et déjà se
dit passer la journée entière sans
jamais le rencontrer
oh la la il n'a pas l'air aimable je
préférerais que c'est surtout qu'ils y
aillent au second véhicule est en colère
pour toi casimir que tu as quelque chose
à craindre
c'est jamais et cusset il a l'air très
nerveux tu devrais y aller toi tu es un
homme et non au contraire toi tu es une
fille avec un grand sourire et beaucoup
de douceur
il redeviendra doux comme un agneau tu
crois c'est certain mais si on tient
peut-être raison messieurs 10 9 aux
chers amis je suis dans un état
épouvantable
il faut que je reprenne tout de suite
une pilule sinon je ne réponds plus de
moi voilà c'était mal mais ça fait une
heure que j'attends quasiment tous avoir
regardé ma chère amie ont regardé cette
main qui tremble comme un vieillard de
92 ans je suis malade
casimir de même rapporté mes pilules et
tout de suite après j'avais rendez vous
avec la plus haute personnalité enfants
c'était une demi heure de retard
une contrainte mais ce drame il conteste
cela n'attend jamais mais devenir en
nourrice non on rentre une souris ma
chère mais voilà ce que je voudrais être
sûr à chaque seconde de la rencontre et
et qu'est ce que je vais lui c'était
pour toi je dise notre calme et doux
revenir tout de suite revenir
pourquoi il est déjà venu mairie deux
fois moi je ne l'est pas mais où est-il
mais chez lui dans sa maison de l'autre
côté de l'île même si je remets monsieur
du smart attendait mais mais qu'est ce
qu'ils ont tous à courir comme sage dans
ces ruines
enfin voilà quoi qui poste de radio
dezeen est déjà de retour
oui et alors mais par où es tu passé en
parant raccourci éméché dix neuf est
parti chez toi pour dire trouver quoi
faut mais il faut toujours qu'il se
distingue celui là enfin il ne pouvais
pas m'attendre ici non je ne veux pas
retourner chez moi moi qui avais
justement pensé à rapporter ces pilules
je t'explique voilà tu sais le foie
quand je suis seul chez moi je m'ennuie
alors grâce au petit livre de cuisine de
julie
je me prépare de succulents gâteaux je
ne sais pas pourquoi
parfois c j'ai du mal entre à les
digérer j'ai mal au ventre et je
n'arrive pas à dormir alors je prends
quelques pilules de monsieur ghislain et
je m'endors tout doucement en écoutant
ton petit poste de radio nous explique
écoute casimir il faut se dépêcher de
rentrer chez toi monsieur duchesneau va
être très sérieux il a peut être besoin
de ces pilules tous les trois possibles
allez un peu de courage
non c'est épouvantable mais coûte cette
info tu oublies toujours touché toi
quand on n'a pas de tête on a des jambes
cette affiche aurait dû faire qu'on
souhaite à cazaux là juste au milieu du
jardin et de courage
allez au revoir ampli home warrick au
milieu du jardin
ça me donne une idée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà bien rangés dans la tente
les pilules de monsieur du snav ne
seront pas perdus saint-casimir moi ça
mais c'est ma nouvelle maison
comment tu comptes habitait là dedans
mais ouais ça n'est pas possible et
pourquoi comment pourquoi parce que
parce que les enfants ne peuvent plus
amusé ici parce que moi je ne peux plus
rentrer dans l'enclos ce que parce que
je ne sais pas moi c'est ça que cacher
quand même casimir françois on nage dans
tous les deux minutes que j'invente une
bêtise car élire mais mais qu'est ce que
c'est que savez vous des futurs fait
jusqu'à cinq millions mais c'est ma
nouvelle maison ta maison
non c'est pas possible tu ne sais plus
quand tu dis c'est toi qui m'a conseillé
d'installer ma maison dans jardin mais
je n'ai jamais dit ça je vais me faire
le plaisir de défaire 70 il vous dit non
non c'est pas possible c'est pourquoi
j'ai remporté tous les outils qui
servent à la démonter chez moi et bien
te du reste plus qu'à y retourner
non ça casimir les enfants vont arriver
d'une minute à l'autre ils vont se
prendre les pieds dans les ficelles
j'ai eu raison c'est très dangereux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va monsieur distincts vous ne vous
êtes pas fait revenir vite
une pilule cas limiers non c'est
absolument impossible
pourquoi tu as tout manger mais non je
vous avais bien rangés dans ma tente
vous avez glissé vous êtes tombé sur la
boîte vous avez tout écraser
[Musique]